america prepares for more black lives
matter allied chaos as the chauvin trial
ends
and the media continue to make excuses
for insurrection from the left
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first
you've heard it said there are only two
sure things in life death and taxes it's
a benjamin franklin
quote well now there's a third if you're
with verizon att or t-mobile switching
to pure talk will certainly
save you money in fact pure talk saves
the average family for over 800
a year here's the best part you don't
have to sacrifice coverage because it's
the exact same network as one of those
providers switching is really easy keep
your phone
and keep your number or you can get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids
right now you can get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month here's the beautiful thing
about this
if you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it so all of
these big wireless companies they'll
tell you you need unlimited data
well you don't need unlimited data you
need unlimited talk and unlimited text
and six gigs of data
for 30 bucks a month especially because
again if you go over pure talk usa isn't
going to charge you for it just one of
the many reasons they've been named the
top wireless provider by consumer
affairs
from your cell phones i'll pound 250 say
ben shapiro you will save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say bend shapiro to get
started pound
two five zero on your cell phone and
then say ben shapiro get started with my
friends over at puretalk usa
and save yourself hundreds of bucks a
year in the process alrighty so this
week we are supposed to get a verdict in
the derek chauvin trial
it could go either way i mean that's
just a frank assessment of the way the
evidence was presented
i thought the defense presentation was
frankly kind of weak i thought the
prosecution presentation as i mentioned
was
frankly kind of weak i think the defense
may have been better off just saying the
prosecution didn't prove its case
the prosecution did not prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that derek chovin
committed either second or third degree
murder or manslaughter
and i think they might have gotten away
with that because the fact is that the
prosecution case did not
really get all the way there in terms of
causation there was serious question
as to whether george floyd died of
excited delirium whether he died
of a drug overdose whether he died of
his pre-existing heart condition
there's a serious question as to whether
derek chovin used a level of force that
was unjustified under the circumstances
to the extent that he would be
prosecuted for manslaughter all of that
may be true maybe not you know there's
certainly doubt
and so for a jury to find reasonable
doubt and all three of these charges
would not be
completely wild it would be kind of wild
to me if you were convicted of murder on
these charges the manslaughter charge is
the one
that seems like the most likely scenario
would be a conviction andy mccarthy over
at national review has sort of a similar
assessment
of the evidence that if you're on the
jury he thinks maybe he might vote in
favor of manslaughter but probably not
in terms of the of the actual murder
charges the judge is going to lay out
the jury instructions and those are
going to make a large difference
in terms of how the jury finds
presumably if the jury has listened to
the case
if that is the case then the defense is
in trouble because the judge has been
extraordinarily biased toward the
prosecution throughout this process
beginning with the pro with the with the
judge's refusal to
move the venue of the trial and then
continuing with the judge's
reinstatement of the third degree murder
charge which really doesn't apply
and then continuing with the judge
allowing a full week of testimony from
onlookers just talking about how
disturbed they were by the entire event
which of course
is not probative in any way and actually
does not constitute any sort of evidence
as to the guilt or innocence of the
party involved
in any case all of this is ancillary and
here's the problem in america folks all
of this is ancillary now
normally in a criminal trial the
criminal trial is the central issue
normally in a criminal trial what's
happening in that courtroom is the
central issue
what happens with the defendant is the
central issue what happened to the
victim is the central issue
in this trial that is not the case and
this has been true in the united states
for quite a while
it is completely ancillary the only
thing that trial is is a wick
okay is the wick going to get lit or is
the wick not going to get lit
if chauvin is convicted the wic
presumably will not be lit if
chauvin is acquitted the the wick will
be lit and there will be
a massive conflagration and everybody
knows this which means
that we have been treated to the
spectacle of the press running around
since january 6th saying that the
largest scale threat to the american
government
the largest scale threat to our way of
life is a bunch of tool bags
running into the capitol building
wearing vikings horns okay now
here's the thing that was terrible i
talked about it extensively i said that
it was some of the worst imagery i've
seen in america since 9 11 the idea
of rioters running into the capitol
building itself
and occupying the speaker seat and
threatening the speaker of the house and
threatening the vice presidents of the
united states
just after the president had spoken and
to be clear that was a breakaway group
there were probably a hundred thousand
people who were there to hear trump
speak
and there was a small group of morons
who decided that would be a great idea
to go take over the capitol building it
was dangerous and it was vile
the notion that this provided some sort
of large-scale threat to the republic
was asinine as proved by the fact that
the minute that those people were
cleared out
congress went right back to its chamber
and did exactly what it was going to do
in the first place
there was never a true threat to
overthrow the government of the united
states on january 6th not in any
practical meaningful way
there's a true threat in the sense that
these people were threatening to do so
but they didn't have the power to do so
what we are watching right now across
the united states however is an attempt
to overthrow
okay we are looking at getting rid of
systems in the united states
specifically on the basis that they are
all corrupted at their root and they
must be torn out
and if it has to happen through violence
it will happen through revolutionary
aggression
motor watching is the rise of left-wing
authoritarianism aided and embedded by
the media and by the democratic party it
is aided and abetted by people in power
if you're talking about an attempt to
overthrow systems of the american
government
you have to pay attention when that is
happening from within the house
in the same way that it would have been
a much bigger story and a much more
important story january 6
if there have been members of congress
or the trump administration actively
colluding with people to overthrow the
republic the notion that you have people
in power in the united states who are
actively willing to overthrow things
like due process
or actively willing to overthrow things
like field teach law
who are actively willing to overthrow
the idea of equal rights under the law
in pursuit of some sort of utopian
equity scheme
that is a form of soft insurrection and
that is deeply and in some cases heart
insurrection
it is deeply disturbing to watch how is
it that we are living in a country where
we are at the point
where we are worried that if the mob
does not get its way in the chauvin
trial
right or wrong if they don't get their
way we know that things will burn
can you think of anything else in
american life that is like this
seriously can you think of any other
example that is like this
where you know that if a group of people
does not get its way
that that group of people will run
around burning things and the media will
cheer them
and members of a major american party
will proceed to clap them on the back
and call them friends
even after the the january 6th incident
did you see lots of republicans emerging
from the woodwork
to talk about how these people were
wonderful and justified can you name
five mainstream republicans who said
this
i can't because they don't exist but you
can't find anybody in the democratic
party to condemn black lives matter
riots
you can't find that if they condemn the
writing they certainly won't condemn the
underlying ideology of the rioting
you won't find five democrats in america
to talk about what's happening in
portland
you won't find five democrats in america
to talk about the simple fact that if
the chauvin trial
does not end with the conviction of
derek chauvin what you will end up with
is the burning down of american cities
and everyone knows this
that's the thing this is not a secret we
all know this is what's going to happen
they're being clear about this imagine
any other cause in american life
where the entire system would just
accept the fact that america is supposed
to shut down and allow things to burn
if a group of people does not get its
way under due process of law in the
united states
we're not even talking about people not
getting their weight in terms of
legislation or people not getting their
way
in terms of a presidential election we
are talking about people not getting
their way
in terms of a conviction of an
individual who is being charged with
murder and manslaughter
and may spend decades in prison if
convicted
can you imagine anything else like this
in america and yet we just accept it
it's just the normal
this is the normal okay well when this
becomes the normal that means the
insurrection is inside the house that
means the insurrection
is not a threat from outside it is a
threat that is being promulgated from
outside and inside it's an inside
outside game this is nothing new in
american politics honestly if you go
back to major american cities in the
1960s when they were burning sometimes
you would have politicians actively
fomenting people outside the government
participating in insurrectionary
behavior so they could turn around and
say i need to appease these people or
they might burn down the house
that's sort of what you are seeing right
now in american politics we'll get to
more of this in just one second because
the the other sort of
casualness with which we are treating
the facts that we all know that america
is going to burn if chauvin doesn't get
convicted
is indicative of something far deeper
and far more scary than anything that
happened on january 6th
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
nobody wants to stand in line at an auto
parts store that's why you ought to use
the internet for this sort of stuff why
would you go to an auto parts store wait
in line you get to the front of the line
finally at the very end of that line you
answer a bunch of questions
and they say they need to order their
part online then they up charge you why
would you do that instead just go to
rockauto.com and cut out the middleman
rock auto is so much easier than walking
into a store and someone demanding
quick answers to things like quote is
your odyssey and alex we're in ex
you're not going to know the answer to
that right off the top of your head
instead just go online answer all the
questions get your part
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much
for the same parts rockauto.com is a
family business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rock auto.com catalog is
unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and write
shapiro in there how did you hear about
xbox so they know
that we sent you okay so according to
axios minnesota is waking up to images
of an occupied city on monday
as the city and the world awaited a
verdict in the derek chauvin trial
residents running errands picking up
dinner and heading to the dog park in
recent days encountered heavily armed
national guard troops
stationed throughout the city some
streets downtown are barricaded as far
from the courthouse as hennepin avenue
and even more businesses across
minneapolis and st
paul are boarded up now we've been
treated to the narrative from the left
that all of washington dc had to be
enclosed in barbed wire because of the
threat of january 6th
and then it turns out that the capitol
police officer the next capital police
officer who was murdered
by somebody attempting to do harm to the
system was in fact a member
of the black hebrew nationalists i
believe right he was he was a radical
nation of islam follower or something
can't remember his exact
affiliation he certainly was not a white
supremacist okay and that story just
disappeared blip gone
right nobody nobody paid attention to it
because it didn't fit the narrative but
the idea behind the
barbs wiring of the capitol was that
this was in on january 6 was an ongoing
ever present threat remember we were
told in the aftermath of january 6th
that on inauguration day there would be
giant protests around the country and
things would burn it didn't happen
but we all know that major american
cities are going to burn because major
american cities are already burning
thanks to the derek chauvin trial and
because of police incidents with people
of color
according to axios for months officials
and residents have braced for the
possibility of more unrest at the
culmination of the trial
operation safety net a centralized
command of state and local law
enforcement was formed to prevent a
repeat of the fires and looting that
followed george floyd's killing last
summer
but the jury deliberations which will
begin following monday's closing
arguments are coming at an especially
fraught time
the police shooting of 20 year old dante
wright in brooklyn center has already
raised
has already raised heightened community
tensions ahead of the verdict
crowd control tactics including tear gag
and other tear gas and other less lethal
munitions
and treatment of the press sparked
intense backlash from protesters local
lawmakers
even doctors the minneapolis city
council passed a largely symbolic
resolution on friday seeking to rein the
operation in some activists and local
lawmakers are calling on governor tim
walls and mayors to dismantle operation
safety net altogether right
these are people who are fine with
people rioting and looting
businesses remain on edge
last week's crime spree targeting twin
cities establishments rattled many given
those stakes leaders in the business
community are also defending operation
safety net
minneapolis regional chamber ceo
jonathan weinhagen told the axios quote
safety net has been effective and
efficient and done the work it was
supposed to do but that does not mean
that things aren't going to shut down
they are shutting down
according to espn the nba has instructed
teams to be vigilant about the impact of
a potential verdict this week in the
derek chauvin trial for the death of
george floyd in minneapolis including
the possibility of game postponement
sources told espn the looming specter of
possible protest civil unrest and team
reactions in the aftermath of a verdict
has the league office preparing for the
prospect
that a night or two of league games
could be postponed this week sources
said used to be by the way in the united
states that only a natural disaster or a
world war
would actually postpone national games
like this but now anytime there is a
controversial verdict
on a racial issue we have to postpone
nba games
the minnesota timberwolves and brooklyn
net postponed a game last week
after the police shot an unarmed black
man dante wright during a traffic stop
in brooklyn center
minnesota the timberwolves started a
four-game seven-day western conference
road trip
on sunday in los angeles the the nba and
wnba postponed a full slate of playoff
games after another black man jacob
blake was shot by police in kenosha
wisconsin during the nba restart in
orlando florida
the milwaukee bucks boycotted a playoff
game against the orlando magic
triggering a full stoppage of league
games for three days that was not
because of fear of violence that was
because members of the league decided
they were full
on in favor of people burning things and
rooting and rioting and looting
apparently in favor of jacob blake
a man who had been accused of digital
rape
and who by the way pulled the knife on
police officers
so we are now living in a situation in
which any incident
that is portrayed by the media as a
racial injustice is cause for cities to
burn
and nba games to be postponed and by the
way public schools to go distance
according to minnesota cbs local in
anticipation of a verdict in the derrick
chauvin trial next week
minneapolis public schools said in a
letter to families that all grades will
transition to distance learning
wednesday through friday so children are
being forced home
from school by the way doing amazing
work on behalf of black children in
minneapolis sending them home from
public school
probably that's probably good for the
kids but you send them home because
things are great
keeping kids out of school that's the
solution so they're shutting down all
the schools
between wednesday and friday because of
the chauvin trial
what does this mean it means mob justice
is likely to rule in the chauvin trial
which is bad for derek shove and it also
means that we are living in a country
where we all
expect that mob violence is going to
break out when
things don't go the way that the mob
wants that is not something
that should be expected in a country
that has rule of law if
you have a few things that you can
expect as a citizen of the united states
one
should be you can expect a certain level
of safety and security in your community
not just from cops or supposedly the
deep abiding threats your community
which is a lie
but you should be able to expect that
your community is not going to go up in
flames
you have to be able to expect it every
time there's a criminal trial
or a shooting without any evidence by
the way because we've seen riots and
looting
after incidents that don't even end with
a trial because it turns out that the
shoot was good
we all know how this is going to go the
fact that we expect this is number one
the soft bigotry of low expectations for
black lives matter protesters slash
rioters and number two
part of a full-scale belief by the left
that this is just the armed
insurrectionist wing
of a broader movement that ought to lay
low america's institutions and
ideologies
but these people are just a little too
passionate they're not bad they're not
truly bad they're just passionate
they're not doing anything that's truly
wrong they're just raging out of control
because after all this rage is justified
they if you're talking about the danger
to the systems of the united states
i'm again not talking about the dangers
of racism because
most of these situations in fact i'm i'm
hard-pressed to think
of a situation in the in the past few
years
that has resulted in riots and looting
that eventually ended up being chalked
up to actual racism
usually it's police misconduct police
brutality police accident
or police doing the right thing and it
ends with rioting and looting
but the systems that people wish to tear
down are systems of due process of law
systems of individual justice and
systems of private property these are
systems that blm
explicitly opposes in many cases and
private property being one of them
unless you're patrice colors buying a
1.4 million dollar estate into panga
canyon with all the white folks
and again aided and abetted by the
institutions in our society corporations
are mirroring this the media
mirror this joe biden mirrors this
sure your politicians who don't want to
see things burn because it makes them
look bad we'll say a word every so often
joe biden will say i don't like rioting
and i don't like looting
how about this how about say that the
police are not going out and willie
newton shoot willy-nilly shooting at
black people for no reason
instead you have joe biden out there
saying that black people are being
targeted by the police on the basis of
race
that america has a systemic racism
problem within its police
of course he switches his tune every
time a police officer is killed then he
then he'll stand by the casket and talk
about how wonderful police officers are
but that's not the overarching message
as to how he thinks the system of
policing in the united states works this
is coming from a man who sponsored the
1994 crime bill
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one second because if you are talking
about the real insurrection inside the
united states most dangerous
insurrectionists
and their enablers that is not happening
in terms of the january 16 on crazies
okay that is happening
from a mainstream ideology that has
taken over the democratic party and that
is rife in the media and rife in the
universities and is being
cudgelled into the corporations into the
corporate culture
the institutions under which we live our
lives are being gradually infused with a
viewpoint
that means the overthrow of traditional
american values
and traditional american values is not a
euphemism i mean values expressed in the
declaration of independence and
constitution of the united states
doesn't get more it doesn't get much
more traditional than that we'll get to
more of this in just one second
first let us talk for a second about
your nutrition okay the reality is
that if you want to get healthy and stay
healthy you need to know how to make
decisions because
if you want to stay healthy healthy is a
lifestyle it's not just a diet most
diets
end up with you yo-yoing right you lose
some weight and then you gain some
weight and you don't stick with it
nume is a habit-changing system and that
is what nume is there to do they give
you the knowledge
tools and confidence to make strategic
choices that turn into long-term habits
those long-term habits turn into a
healthy happier you
noom is based in science built by
psychologists noom doesn't give you
rules instead teaches you how to think
so you can accomplish your personal
health goals stick with them long-term
and get healthy for good
based in psychology noom will teach you
why you make the choices you do
and give you the tools to replace your
habits with healthier ones noom's
cognitive behavioral approach means
you're not just improving your health
you're getting the knowledge and habits
you need to stay healthy that is super
important because again you've got to
get nutrition and health into your
lifestyle and nume
helps you do this by changing the way
you think over 80 percent of numerous
finish the program over 60
have stuck with their goals for at least
one year which is huge there is a
science
getting healthier it's called new my
wife has been using numa i've been using
noom sign up for your trial today at
noon
n-o-o-m.com shapiro learn how to get
healthy with noom sign up for your trial
today
noom noom.com shapiro that's n-o-o-m.com
shapiro okay again this is this is part
and parcel
this mentality that if the chauvin trial
doesn't go the way that people want it
to go that things burn that's part of a
broader mentality which is that if we
don't get our way the systems of the
united states are to blame because
america's systems are corrupt and they
need to be torn down to the root
so chris cuomo and this is enabled by
your media first of all before we even
get to the media
let me just say that there are incidents
all over the united states the media
just don't want to cover his national
issues
and what counts as a national issue is a
data point that backs a media narrative
or even a data point that doesn't quite
fit into the media narrative but could
be theoretically interpreted to
maybe fit into the media narrative those
are stories that are national stories
kermit gosnell
killing babies after they're born
doesn't fit into the media narrative
about abortions that's a local crime
story
derek chovin is a national news story
because you can maybe if you twist it
and turn it
and view it through the the prism of
systemic races
maybe you can get to the idea that
george floyd died because of deep-seated
american racism as opposed to george
floyd's own actions and resisting arrest
his
his being high as a kite on fentanyl his
previous health condition
and maybe the misapplication of forced
by derrick shelvin right if you twist it
and turn it you can fit into the
narrative so maybe it is a national news
story but there are other stories that
are not national news stories because
they don't fit the narrative
like for example cops being attacked in
molotov cocktails in new york city
this of course is never going to fit the
narrative so you had a situation
in which the police had a some sort of
chemical thrown on them they followed
the guy
he proceeded to get out of his car and
throw a molotov cocktail at them and
then when they arrested him they found a
bunch of other relative cocktails
in his car here's a little bit of body
cam footage from the from the incident
what are you going out for huh what are
you going out for i got to look
at my wallet well that's fine you can
open the door if you want
when we get out
oh
oh but why should why should traffic
cops have uh have guns well why should
the cops be able to defend themselves
obviously people
getting pulled over are never going to
do anything bad meanwhile suspect fired
at cops in georgia
and non-national news story because even
though it does fit a narrative which is
that suspects
very often do resist arrest and cops
have to do things to stop those suspects
you don't want to hear about those
incidents because that might lend
a bit of nuance to how we treat police
activity in the united states where
there are well over
40 40 million police civilian
interactions
every single year in the united states
and fewer than 20 of them generally end
in the death of an unarmed black person
or at least the shooting of an unarmed
black man we don't know the statistics
on on
non-shootings but it can't be much
higher than that considering that guns
are the most common weapon used
in the majority of these cases
presumably okay here for example is a
situation in georgia where a suspect
fired a cops was this a national news
story of course now this is from the
carroll county sheriff's office
yeah how does that look to you doug's
safe to you
as a that is a suspect picking up a
rifle and shooting at the cops now
have you heard a lot of calls for uh for
gun control on the base of this
particular footage
nope because this footage does not fit
the narrative
you call for gun control when it's a
white person shooting up a walmart you
don't call for gun control when it is a
a suspect of color shooting at the cops
using a gun like that
then you just ignore it and it's not a
national news story then you literally
just don't talk about it then it's just
not a national news story
in any way shape or form and
the again the insurrectionist viewpoint
here that the united states is evil and
needs to be overthrown from the inside
if possible
and forced from the outside if necessary
has become extremely common
on a wide variety of topics in this area
maxine now we get to the media and we
get to the democrats who are who are
softly backing this sort of stuff again
the rioting in portland has been ongoing
for months at this point as john sexton
points out at hot air
riding and arsing rioting and arson in
portland have been continuing for
literally months there was a fatal
police shooting at a park in portland
friday morning it started when a call
was placed to the cops reporting a white
man pointing a gun in the park police
arrived according to a witness who
filmed the encounter the man became
irate he was shirtless didn't appear to
be armed at that point though the
witness said he hit him with a gun
earlier
police attempted to issue orders and
locate the gun the man bent down and
picked something off
off the ground one of the officers shot
him and the man died at the scene
now again you notice that's not a
national news story because it's a white
person getting shot by the cops
friday evening there were two protests
announced an antifa account called for
occupation of the park where the
shooting happened
they said that blm was not welcome
because
quote this is again according to antifa
to be clear black unity and blm squad
are not welcome at the occupation
because all they do is bring megaphones
to exploit portland's white guilt and
swoop bleep
okay sounds kind of racist both the
antifa and blm march blocked traffic but
the antifa march was eventually declared
a right it was the third riot in five
days
and you know of course had the footage
because this is some of the stuff that
he covers you can see
portland burning
[Music]
[Applause]
and they targeted the portland
historical society and the first
christian church in downtown portland
they spray painted no more history on
the oregon historical society which
i mean at least they're saying the quiet
part out loud right there
they tried they targeted nordstrom and
nike so all of nike's wokeness didn't
buy them any help
from antifa meanwhile and they painted
killed cops on the side of buildings
which is always great
meanwhile rioters decided that they were
going to go hog wild in oakland as well
apparently they breached a target it was
a very racist target so that needed to
be stopped they smashed out the windows
of a target and started looting
uh that was that was a really good way
to uh to fight american racism is by
targeting
the target in new york there was there
was scuffling between the police
and protesters in washington dc groups
were launching
fireworks at people and having
altercations between police and
protesters protesters were trying to
disturb people dining
they were they were chanting about how
you're dining while people are dying
which is literally true all over the
world actually it turns out that every
time somebody is eating somebody is
simultaneously dying
on planet earth who knew okay and when i
say that this is being fomented
and and encouraged by members of the
media i don't know any other way to read
it
other than the the media really
kind of tutting this stuff pretending
that it doesn't really matter because
again
these are just the most ardent of the of
the protesters
it is not that they are doing something
that is different in kind they're just
doing something that's different in
degree
which is why it's not a big deal to the
left when maxine waters says that black
lives matter should get more
confrontational if chauvin isn't
convicted
this is the same woman who declared
during the la riots that it was the la
uprising
the same woman who declared just a few
years ago that you should actively
confront members of the trump
administration if you see them in public
so it's not a surprise to hear
maxine waters generating sympathy for
people who
to get actively violent we've got to
fight for justice
but i am very hopeful and i hope
that we're going to get a verdict
that can say guilty guilty guilty and if
we don't
we cannot go away what should protesters
do
well we got to stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more
active you've got to get more
confrontational
we've got to make sure that they they
know that we need business
they have to know that we resist a
verdict in a court of law that we resist
this
hey how's that anything but sympathy for
people who are riding and looting i'm
having a hard time finding any
rational interpretation here other than
that we have to get more confrontational
we have to stay on the streets
imagine if if republican lawmakers said
the exact same thing in the aftermath of
january 6th can you name any who did
seriously i can't maxine waters have
been saying this stuff for 30 years in
congress and not a democrat will condemn
her not one
there won't be a single one meanwhile
the media providing cover for this sort
of stuff even in soft ways
again soft bigotry of low expectations
with regard to behavior so cnn miguel
martinez
he was at some of these riots the other
night in minneapolis
and some of these protesters went over
and started attempting to confront
as maxine waters might say the members
of the media and here's miguel martinez
kind of ah
you know they're just angry somebody hit
me with a water bottle and then we sort
of just started moving toward our cars
they continued to sort of pelt us with
whatever they could find uh we got in
the car and we took off i i cannot
blame them for being angry but you know
a lot of people are very angry
suspicious of the press the corporate
media all those things come into it at
these places
and uh it was just one of those
situations that it was intense
there were people who were angry at
everything and everybody
and we happened to be in the wrong place
at the wrong time oh we happen to mean
actually no you were in the right place
at the right time doing what is called
reporting and then a bunch of people
acting like garbage decided to attack
journalists it's unbelievable this is on
cnn
i cannot blame them for being angry now
just imagine for a second
that there's been a crowd of trump
protesters angry
at everything from covington catholic
coverage from cnn
to the russia collusion nonsense push by
cnn for years and imagine that they had
actually started assaulting journalists
it would be a national news story it
would be a national news story about how
trump supporters are viciously
anti-media how trump had driven the
violence and how the true authorian
authoritarian threat against the press
in the united states is coming from the
right
right and we all know this cnn tried to
generate that story even without
evidence that people were really
targeting the press in mass numbers
they tried to generate that for years
and yet here you have active examples
of rioters and looters and protesters
who are actively
mobbing and harming journalists and you
have the journalists themselves
saying they were very angry i can't
blame them the reason you can't blame
them is because you agree with them
that is why you can't blame them because
you the objective journalists have taken
the view that they are correct on the
merits
and because they're correct on the
merits they're just your allies they're
just your allies who are a little out of
control
they're just your allies who may have
gone just a little bit too far
if that isn't fomenting the ongoing
insurrection against systems of justice
in the united states i don't know what
is you're literally you're literally
saying okay you hit me in the head with
a water bottle but you know what
you know what your heart was in the
right place your aim was off but your
heart was in the right place because
they're just
they're against the corporate media you
know they're just against the system and
we're against the system too they just
don't know we're against the system we
were in the wrong place at the wrong
time
because if we were in the right place at
the right time what we really would have
been we would have been standing next to
them
is the reality that's an it's an
unbelievable quote
from from a so-called journalist i can't
blame them
name a situation anywhere else on earth
where you would say i can't blame the
protesters for attacking journalists can
you name
one seriously can you name a situation
where journalists are like yeah i got
attacked by the protesters but you know
what their heart was in the right place
so really it's my fault
really it's my fault again this part
it's part and parcel of a broader
narrative pushed by the american left
that you can do anything you want
so long as you are anti the system it
plays into the whole system of white
supremacy narrative that is generated by
the same cnn
here's chris cuomo the other day saying
police reform is only not happening
because it's black people getting shot
which is statistically untrue
more white people are shot by the cops
every year than black people
and yet here is chris cuomo adult of the
century suggesting
and by the way congenital liar when it
comes to coverage of his brother
and and corrupt his all get out here he
is still on cnn but still reporting on
cnn
suggesting that police reform only
starts when white people's kids get shot
by the cops
gun laws access to weapons oh you i know
when they'll change
your kids start getting killed white
people's kids start getting killed
smoking that doobie that's actually
legal probably in your state now but
they don't know what it was and then the
kid runs and it pop pop pap pap
cop was justified why'd you run oh he
had a baseball game tonight
oh the white kid oh big family that
house over there
those start piling up
is going on with these police what a
joke our media are
and not not just a joke a dangerous
danger
you know it's not a joke because it's
serious they're just i mean this is
dangerous stuff they are fomenting
narratives about the united states that
are untrue
and in the process they're making
excuses for people who are riding and
they've been doing it for months okay
this is nothing new they've been doing
this going back a year
they were making excuses for the mostly
peaceful protests that were breaking out
all around america cities okay by the
same standard that what was going on in
kenosha wisconsin or la or washington or
chicago or new york or any other major
american city that broke into flames
during the george floyd riots
by that same token january 6 was a
mostly peaceful protest
because most of the people there didn't
go into the capitol building that is not
how that bleep works
okay but the media again are they are
invested
in this lie they are invested in the
insurrectionist cause which again is to
tear down equal systems of justice in
the united states due process of law in
the united states individual rights in
the united states i believe that we
should be treated as individuals in the
united states
a belief that you have actual rights to
your property
and against government right all that
has to be torn down
and if that means incentivizing a few
people to go looted foot locker then you
know what that's just the way things are
going to go
if it means incentivizing minneapolis
schools to shut down for two days so
kids can't go to school
no problem if it means making sure that
nba games are canceled if it means
making sure that we all
are on notice we the american citizen
the body politic we are on notice
that should this trial go the wrong way
your city burns and we will just cover
it
and if we get hit in the coverage by the
by the rioters that's our fault guys
because they're really good-hearted
they're just angry they're just angry
they're complicit in this they're
fomenting
this okay that does not mean that they
are individually responsible
for men for people going and committing
criminal acts because again human beings
have agency but you are part of a
broader movement that makes excuses for
this crap
no question because you're doing broader
good right that's the idea and it's our
politicians everybody from maxine waters
when joe biden proclaims that america is
systemically racist and its police are
systematically racist but by the way
don't riot and loot
how do you think people are going to
take that when you make excuses for
people being on the streets
and rioting and not protesting rioting
and looting when you make excuses for
them by saying things like the media are
saying well they're just angry
they're just angry it would be better if
they didn't write in loop but they're
just they're angry
and let's be let's be frank our police
are bad what do you think is going to
happen
seriously how stupid do you think the
american people are
we now have an expectation that this is
going to an expectation not
it happens and we're shocked not it
happens and we react by going what the
hell is going on
this happens and we expect it it is as
it is like the sun
rising in the east every time there is
some sort of racial
not even racial incident a projected
racial incident by the media
we know things will burn that's part of
the system now
the insurrection is part of the system
now okay which means that things happen
and we're not even surprised at them
anymore things that should be surprising
and shocking
are not surprising to us for example the
former santa rosa home of very broad
is santa rosa cbs reporting very broad
testified as a defense witness in the
derek shove and murder trial
it was smeared his home his former home
was smeared with animal blood
a severed pig's head was dumped on the
front porch in an early saturday morning
vandalism attack don't worry it's not a
national news story guys not a national
news story
because after all he did testify for the
defense now imagine
that one of the witnesses in the george
floyd killing
had a headache white supremacist arrive
on their doorstep paint it with blood
and dump a pig's head on the doorstep
would that be a national news story you
think
would that lead news coverage for a week
you bet but barry broad testifies for
the defense and somebody
covers his former home where they
thought he lived in blood and dumps a
pig head on his front door
no problem whatsoever investigators
believe the vandals thought that broad
still lived at the residence but he
hasn't been a santa rosa
resident for a number of years
just beautiful beautiful stuff happening
in our country and all this this is all
part of the healing
don't you feel the healing breaking out
when i say the media are complicit in
this sort of stuff i mean they're
complicit in this sort of stuff
jason nguyen is an emmy-nominated
investigative reporter
in utah for abc he tweeted out
a picture of a man entering a home in
utah it was reported by the guardian as
well
okay the picture of the man what did
this man do he was a utah paramedic
he had the temerity to donate i believe
ten 10
to kyle rittenhouse's defense in
wisconsin hal rittenhouse of course is
the 17 year old
who shot and killed a person during the
kenosha wisconsin riot
he claims in self-defense and the tape
tends to back him up somebody donated
money to his legal defense fund
the media went to his door and took a
picture of him entering his house
this is not journalism this is activism
which is of course why the journalists
you're seeing are fully in league with
the activists they're like we're on the
same side man i'm just holding a camera
we know alrighty coming up we'll get
into the broader argument which is that
everything in america is racist
america's history america's institutions
everything in america
and that justifies the insurrectionist
attitude that we are seeing throughout
the media throughout our politics and on
the streets of the united states
first it's almost time for another new
episode of candace this week's special
guest dana white president of the
ultimate fighting championship which is
the largest mixed martial arts mma
organization
on planet earth under dana's leadership
the ufc has grown into a globally
popular
multi-billion dollar enterprise the show
streams on fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central at dailywire.com you can get the
audio podcast canvas
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast so
if you need some candice owens in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
you can also become a daily wire member
by going to dailywire.com
subscribe we have a ton of great content
including our new show my new show
debunked it also airs every friday in
which i take
a leftist myth and debunk it again if
you're not a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe join today by the way we need
your membership because the reality is
that the big tech bro companies want to
toss us offline right and they want to
toss everybody on the right offline
the way that you protect against that is
by becoming a member so that we can
continue to bring you the content you
want and we just go right around their
systems go to dailywire.com
subscribe join today you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
again the narrative when it comes to
january 6 is that it was part of a
broader american movement where's the
broader american movement
where is it where's the broader american
movement that seeks to overthrow
america's institutions
completely rewrite them destroy them
from the inside get rid of rights in the
constitution of the united states get
rid of the notion of individual rights
where is that
seriously where is the broad movement
what i see was some nuts
because statistically speaking that's
what we were watching
it was like several hundred people but
what i'm watching on the other side is
institutions that have been completely
collapsing from the inside
in favor of a mentality that says that
america's
basic notion of itself is not only wrong
and unjustified but needs to be torn
asunder
okay which is why you have people like
lz granderson appearing on abc's this
week saying that america continues to be
white supremacist
in terms of margaery grain and that
particular caucus
um in denouncing her many republicans
talked about how america wasn't built on
these ideas
the reality is this country was built on
white supremacy
and the reason why she supported because
white supremacy is still very much a
part of the american fabric
so until we can acknowledge that we're
going to constantly we're going to have
facial issues particularly we're going
to have to we're going to have to end
there but you made your point
and martha raddatz everybody here is uh
is nodding along
it's very important that everybody nod
along to all of this nonsense because if
you if you don't nod along this means
that you're not woke it means that you
don't understand america's
horrific history with race it means that
you're it means that you're just
you're not part of the movement if you
don't not along to this sort of stuff by
the way what lz
anderson is referring to there is the
fact that they're some of the
more right-wing members of the
republican talks including fringe
members like marjory taylor-greene
who have posited that they wanted to
create an america first caucus
that america first caucus was supposed
to work toward an infrastructure that
reflects the architectural engineering
and aesthetic value that
that befits the progeny of european
architecture
right basically people saying they don't
want brutalist architecture they want to
see
you know things that look like classical
roman architecture that is heard
the architecture that has traditionally
characterized washington dc
also the seven-page document outlining
the vision of the proposed
american america first caucus mentioned
the term anglo-saxon
they talked about anglo-saxon heritage
okay and this was treated of course
as evidence of deep abiding american
racism because
how dare you mention anglo anglo-saxon
heritage i have a piece of awkward news
for folks
when it comes to the law and our systems
those are of anglo-saxon
extraction they just are anglo-american
legal systems have been discussed
by virtually every american president
including by the way barack obama
who not all that long ago was talking
about the importance of
habeas corpus on the floor of the senate
and talked about our anglo-american
legal heritage weird because it must be
racist at barack obama
the world is watching what we do here
today in america
they will know what we do here today and
they'll treat all of us accordingly
in the future our soldiers our diplomats
our journalists
anyone who travels beyond these borders
i hope we remember this as we go forward
i sincerely hope that we can protect
what's been called the great writ
a writ that's been in place in the
anglo-american
legal system for
over 700 years by the way you can see
how all of this has shifted
over the course of time for the
democrats how terms that are not racist
are now being treated as racist
if you believe that anglo anglo-saxon
heritage is somehow a is somehow a rip
on people who are not of anglo-saxon
extraction
i'm jewish okay i have no dog in this
anglo-saxon heritage routine
i'm of jewish extraction so i like
antonin scalia
am not somebody who feels that that
particular
ethnic description fits me but here's
antonin scalia in italian
talking about how anglo-saxon heritage
shaped the united states
this is not a matter of historical
conjecture this is a matter of
historical fact here's
here you can call it racist as much as
you want but the simple fact is that
there are many good things about our
anglo-saxon heritage
as a culture those are good nobody is
saying that everybody in america needs
to be anglo-saxon i'd be out
right so it's scalia so probably half
the country
here's anson and scalia making exactly
this point just a few years back in
2006.
the french swiss professors i had
would refer constantly to les pay
anglo sax the anglo-saxon countries
meaning england the united states
australia new zealand
okay canada i said you know hey
my name is scalia and i'm as american as
anybody look at this face is this an
anglo-saxon face
i had never been in england but at the
end of my year
i went to england and i felt at home
there is there is no doubt that american
culture
american common culture which nobody has
to belong to
originates with english culture
okay why is that even remotely
controversial it's controversial because
anything is evident
that the true threat to america is this
intense white supremacy that continues
to govern our lives despite the fact and
it's pretty incredible that in the white
supremacist country a thoroughgoing
white supremacist country you can expect
that every five minutes or so there's
going to be a riot looting justified by
the media
and then tutted by democrats while
saying that the writers and looters have
the justification of good on their side
and of course all this ties in that that
broader american narrative that is being
pushed by the left is about tearing away
at the at the civil institutions of the
society it's about tearing away
any common commonality we have between
ourselves
separate from racial tribalism
it's about making the country a worse
place on the basis of the argument that
america is already a terrible place
and it's not true america is not a
terrible place it is not a terrible
place for black people
it is not a terrible place for white
people it's not a terrible place for
green people
it is in fact the best country on earth
to live if you're a black person
name another country you would rather
live if you are if you're black
seriously i don't know i don't know
another country where i'd rather live
as a jew it's an amazing amazing country
why the the intense push by the left to
rewrite the american bargain
on the back of lies about what america
is and then
to wink and nod at people who are
engaging in
acts of vandalism looting rioting
burning arson
attacks on police officers and to treat
that as not some form
of larger insurrectionist attempt to
overthrow these institutions in the soft
non-legal sense
i don't know what you're watching i
don't know what you're watching you have
a right as an american
to expect that the systems of power in
the united states the systems of
government under the constitution that
are constrained by the constitution of
the declaration
are not overthrown by by people who wish
to see them die
but uh i'll say that that right is
certainly being infringed alrighty we'll
be back here later today
for additional hour of the ben shapiro
show in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show where he discusses
canada
announcing a public health dictatorship
you can hear more details about that
story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
morin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
maxine waters calls for more leftist
street violence the public health regime
becomes permanent
and anglo-saxons get cancelled check it
out on the michael knowles show
[Music]
you